[Música]
un ataque a la capital ucraniana que
comenzó Poco después de la medianoche
Ucrania denunció que al menos 40 drones
rusos entraron al espacio aéreo de kiev
justo en el día que la ciudad celebra el
aniversario de su fundación según las
autoridades ucranianas la ofensiva
comenzó a las dos de la mañana y la
fuerza aérea derribó 58 de los 59
aviones no tripulados que fueron
lanzados en todo el país
Pese a que el jefe de la Administración
militar de kiev asegura que este fue uno
de los ataques con drones más grandes
desde que comenzó la guerra en febrero
de 2022 el número de bajas fue mínimo y
los escombros de los drones
interceptados causaron incendios al
suroeste de la capital
atemorizantes
y luego llegaron las explosiones ni
siquiera tengo palabras Simplemente no
hay palabras
vimos como el dron pasó volando y vimos
el trabajo de la defensa aérea pero
cuando llegó hubo una explosión golpeó
fuerte Rusia nos está destruyendo
intimidándonos pero creo que se trata de
la desesperación de su régimen
ante una reiterada contraofensiva
anunciada por keff
moscúa ha intensificado sus ataques
aéreos principalmente a sitios y
suministros militares ucranianos tan
solo en mayo se han registrado 14 de
ellos Rusia también ha visto atacado su
propio territorio durante las últimas
semanas luego de ofensivas de artillería
morteros y drones en la región
fronteriza sur de Bel